Jacob entered the care system age five, moved between foster homes, endured a failed adoption, and still became one of the youngest trainee psychologists in the country. But the real story isn't that he made it, it's what he had to unlearn, survive and rebuild along the way. If you've ever wondered what resilience and compassion really look like, this conversation will stay with you. If you find it helpful, like and subscribe for more. Hi, I just want to welcome along our guest for today, Jacob and Masparo Batayo. Hi, Jacob. Hi, Marianne. Thanks for having me on the podcast. I'm really excited to be here.
雅各布五岁时进入了照护系统，在不同的寄养家庭间辗转，经历了一次失败的收养，但最终还是成为了全国最年轻的心理学实习生之一。但真正的故事不在于他成功了，而在于他一路走来必须克服、幸存并重建的一切。如果你曾好奇韧性和同理心究竟是什么样子的，这段对话会让你久久难忘。如果你觉得有帮助，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，我想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾，雅各布·马斯帕罗·巴塔约。嗨，雅各布。嗨，玛丽安。谢谢你邀请我参加播客。我很高兴能来到这里。
I'm excited to host you. And you and I have been in each other's DMs for almost three years now because I checked earlier. And it's, yeah, been really lovely sort of following a little bit of your story. Could you tell us a little bit about you if that's okay, Jacob? Yeah, definitely. So three years. that sounds like a really long time. But I suppose my story did start about three years ago when I kind of finished my undergraduate degree in psychology. And I then started the search for assistant psychologist posts.
我很高兴能接待你。我查了一下，我们俩在私信里已经聊了快三年了。看到你的一点点成长故事，真的很美好。雅各布，如果可以的话，你能向我们介绍一下你自己吗？当然可以。三年，听起来是很长一段时间。但我认为我的故事确实是从三年前开始的，当时我刚完成了心理学本科学位。然后我就开始寻找助理心理学家的职位。
And clinical psychology is always something that I've been interested in. And I suppose it was from there that I then started looking. But underpinning all of this is the fact that I have care experience and I grew up care experienced. And I think that's been a really important part of my journey that has kind of given me a different lens on what it means to be a clinical psychologist and kind of what makes a good clinical psychologist. So it's definitely given me a different spin on the career. Absolutely it has. Could you define the term care experience for anyone who might not be sure, Jacob? Yeah, this is a really interesting and important definition. I think older definitions used to kind of speak about care
临床心理学一直是我感兴趣的领域。我想就是从那时起我开始寻找机会。但这一切的基础是我有照护经历，我是在照护系统中长大的。我认为这是我人生旅程中非常重要的一部分，它让我对临床心理学家的意义以及什么样的人能成为优秀的临床心理学家有了不同的视角。所以这确实让我的职业生涯有了不同的色彩。绝对是这样。雅各布，你能为那些不太确定的人定义一下“照护经历”这个词吗？是的，这是一个非常有趣且重要的定义。我认为旧的定义通常会谈论照护
experience in so much as having, I think it was 20 days of experience being cared for by a corporate parenting system. And a corporate parenting system is a kind of a system of professionals that aim to keep you safe and to keep you kind of cared for, essentially. whereas nowadays care experience is something that we most kind of more progressive and compassionate services will view as any length of time that you have been kind of inexperience of a corporate parenting system but also really importantly if you have been estranged from your family if you're not in contact with your family for any reason and you've had to kind of go at life alone for a certain period of time, that also counts as kind of having that care experience.
经历，即有20天的被企业化育儿系统照护的经历。企业化育儿系统是一套旨在确保你安全并让你得到基本照护的专业人员系统。而如今，大多数进步且富有同情心的服务机构会将照护经历视为你在企业化育儿系统中经历的任何时长。但同样重要的是，如果你与家人疏远，因任何原因与家人失去联系，并且在一段时间内不得不独自面对生活，这也算作拥有照护经历。
And I think that's a really important kind of distinction to make. So thank you for bringing that up. Well, thank you for sharing your experiences so kind of honestly and openly. And if we're really getting nuts and bolts about this, why is it harder for someone who's care experienced to have a professional career-specific? in psychology. Yeah, yeah. And it is, it can be harder. And it, you know, I can share some of my experience, which might be helpful. So for me, I think, you know, there's this real essence of when you're applying or when you're looking to apply to become a trainee clinical psychologist, which, you know, I've managed to do, there is this sense of, you know, how far back in your
我认为这是一个非常重要的区别。谢谢你提出这一点。好吧，谢谢你如此诚实和坦率地分享你的经历。如果我们深入探讨核心问题，为什么有照护经历的人在心理学领域从事专业职业会更难？是的，确实会更难。我可以分享一些我的经历，希望能有所帮助。对我来说，我认为在申请或寻求成为临床心理学实习生时（我已经做到了），人们会关注你申请时回溯到你
history does this application look at? Some will look at A level, some I think used to even look at GCSEs. And I think for me, I remember when I was doing my GCSEs, I was not a perfect student. I didn't really care about doing my GCSEs. I think that's quite a shared experience with so many different people as well. So yeah, I think for me, that's where things kind of started. That's when I was having quite a difficult time of my life. And then A levels as well, that's when I did psychology off the cuff. I didn't mean to do psychology. I was doing fine art, French and photography and decided, I don't really like the photography teacher. So my friend was set opposite to me and said, well, psychology is in that kind of part of the timetable. Do you want to just switch over? And sort of,
历史的哪个阶段？有些会看A-level成绩，有些甚至会看GCSE成绩。我记得我在读GCSE时，并不是一个完美学生。我根本不在乎GCSE成绩。我想这与许多人的经历很相似。所以是的，我认为对我来说，事情就是从那里开始的。那是我人生中相当艰难的时期。然后是A-level，我当时是临时决定学心理学的。我本来没打算学心理学。我当时在学美术、法语和摄影，但我决定我不喜欢摄影老师。我旁边的朋友对我说，心理学就在那个时间段，你想换过去吗？
I think it was one of the last days. I did switch over to psychology. And, and, and, and, I really enjoyed it, which is really lucky. But I suppose from then on is when I kind of had this newfound interest for what can I do with this knowledge. This feels important to use. I think we'd learn about kind of Bulby's monotropic theory of attachment and the still face and all of those things felt really important. And how do I translate them into practice? So that's when I looked into, you know, what can I do with this? And clinical psychology was of course, you know, has always been for quite a long time the way that you can apply this knowledge into practice.
我想那是最后几天了。我确实换到了心理学，而且我真的很喜欢它，这真的很幸运。但我想从那时起，我就对如何利用这些知识产生了新的兴趣。我觉得利用这些知识很重要。我想我们学习了鲍尔比的依恋理论、“静止脸”实验等等，所有这些都感觉非常重要。我该如何将它们转化为实践呢？所以这就是我研究方向的由来。临床心理学当然一直以来都是将这些知识应用于实践的途径。
And what makes it difficult is, you know, I've spoken about how far does this application look back in your life, but also the kind of emotional aspects that might come with this experience. So when I got to the point of kind of writing the application, what also made it difficult was how much do I disclose of myself? And is this going to be kind of looked at with a compassionate lens? Are people going to see the value in this experience? Or are people going to find this difficult to hold? So there is this real kind of tension between how much of yourself do you want to bring? And I think I've always been the person that will kind of champion.
困难之处在于，正如我所说，申请时会回溯到你人生的哪个阶段，还有伴随这种经历的情感层面。当我写申请书时，另一个困难是：我该披露多少关于自己的信息？这会被以同情的眼光看待吗？人们会看到这段经历的价值吗？还是人们会觉得这很难接受？所以，在你想要展现多少自我之间存在着真正的张力。我想我一直是一个会支持
I'm happy to take on that responsibility of championing. care experience people, not that it is kind of any one person's responsibility, but it's something that I've always felt particularly passionate about. So there is that emotional aspect. And then when you're on training, you know, I know we were speaking about earlier, Marian, the difficulties that can come up with therapeutic relationships and how they can replicate some of those difficult dynamics. So there is a real kind of felt sense of, is this going to be difficult for me? And I suppose along with that, the systemic barriers, the ones that are kind of harder to change and kind of always there.
我很高兴承担起支持照护经历人群的责任，并不是说这是某一个人的责任，但这一直是我特别热衷的事情。所以存在情感层面。当你进入培训时，正如我们之前谈到的，玛丽安，治疗关系中可能会出现困难，它们可能会重现那些困难的动态。所以有一种真实的感受：这对我会很难吗？我想随之而来的是系统性障碍，那些更难改变且总是存在的障碍。
And I suppose, you know, luckily clinical psychology is a training program that you're paid to do, which is, you know, why I think for more and more care experienced and estranged people, that that's kind of the pathway that they want to go down when they think about applying for, you know, a way that they can apply their psychological knowledge. But before that, there's this kind of period of time where you need to build some experience and to do that, you might have to take on kind of an assistant psychologist post that is often a band four. I know there are some band fives and if you are a band five, that's very lucky. I think a lot of us are banned for, or not anymore, but yeah, it's a difficult salary to live with. And for a lot of people as well that are care experience, psychology isn't their first career. They kind of established themselves.
我想，幸运的是，临床心理学是一个带薪的培训项目，这就是为什么我认为越来越多的有照护经历和疏远家庭的人，在考虑如何应用他们的心理学知识时，会选择这条道路。但在那之前，有一段时间你需要积累经验，为此你可能不得不担任通常是四级的助理心理学家职位。我知道有一些五级职位，如果你能拿到五级，那非常幸运。我想我们很多人都是四级，或者不再是了，但这是一个很难维持生活的薪水。对于许多有照护经历的人来说，心理学也不是他们的第一职业。他们已经建立了自己，
I know I've got some friends that were teachers that, and I've had these really well-established professional identities, that they earn good enough money to have a family on, and then you kind of have to go back from there. So that can be really difficult. And I think one of my particular gripes, I would say, in, and it's a difficult thing to talk about, is the kind of the fact that when you apply as well, you have to have a BPS accredited psychology degree,
我知道我有一些朋友以前是老师，他们拥有非常成熟的职业身份，赚的钱足以养家糊口，然后你不得不从头开始。这可能真的很困难。我认为我特别不满的一点是，这是一个很难谈论的话题，那就是当你申请时，你必须拥有英国心理学会（BPS）认证的心理学学位，
And I think for me, I can only draw from my experience, I've always found that useful to have. For me, that's always been really useful knowledge to apply on training so far. And lots of people won't have that. And lots of people won't have it because maybe the degree that they had wasn't BPS accredited for one reason or another. So I think it's a really difficult tension to hold, but those are kind of a few of the barriers when your care experience. And, you know, of course, one of the largest ones is the emotional and the kind of support networks,
对我来说，我只能从我的经验出发，我一直觉得拥有这个很有用。对我来说，到目前为止，在培训中应用这些知识一直非常有用。很多人没有这个学位。很多人没有是因为他们获得的学位由于某种原因没有获得BPS认证。所以我认为这是一个很难处理的张力，但这些就是当你拥有照护经历时会遇到的一些障碍。当然，最大的障碍之一是情感和支持网络，
because training can be really hard. And a lot of care experience and estranged people won't have that. But those are a few, and I hope I've given them justice, but there will be so many more. Yeah. Absolutely. And it's listening to you. I was kind of thinking of, I don't know, maybe some parallels that were just, well, not even parallels, like opposites really. Like, I used to have to get up really early to do some of my early aspiring jobs. So I was a home carer. Best job ever. Loved it. But obviously, you're having to get up before people have their breakfast. So I was getting up really early. My dad would get up early and we'd call it our first breakfast, really our first breakfast together. then I'd go off and go and get all my clients up out of bed and give them their breakfast. Then I'd come home for like my second breakfast.
因为培训可能真的很艰难。许多有照护经历和疏远家庭的人不会有这些。但这些只是一部分，我希望我能公正地对待它们，但还会有更多。是的，绝对是。听你说话时，我在想，我不知道，也许是一些平行线，或者说不是平行线，而是对立面。我以前为了做一些早期的职业工作不得不很早起床。我曾是一名家庭护理员。这是最好的工作。我爱它。但显然，你必须在人们吃早餐前起床。所以我起得很早。我爸爸会早起，我们称之为我们的第一顿早餐，真正的第一顿早餐。然后我就去叫醒我的客户，给他们做早餐。然后我回家吃我的第二顿早餐。
My dad had gone to work by then. But it was someone that just wanted to spend that time with me. And when I was growing up, before that was older than my first job was working in boots in Milton Keynes. But I just decided on a whim to apply because I obviously wanted some money and I thought the job sounded good. But it was 10 miles away from where I lived and just expected that my parents will drive. me there and back on a Saturday and a Sunday. And even that, like for someone it's care experienced, you haven't necessarily got that companionship and you haven't got someone that is your taxi necessarily. Like it's just harder to even get started in those early roles, let alone the pay
那时我爸爸已经去上班了。但那是有人想花时间陪我。在我成长过程中，在那之前，我的第一份工作是在米尔顿凯恩斯的Boots工作。我只是心血来潮申请了，因为我显然想要一些钱，而且我觉得这份工作听起来不错。但它离我住的地方有10英里远，我只是理所当然地认为我父母会在周六和周日开车送我往返。即使是这样，对于一个有照护经历的人来说，你未必有那种陪伴，也未必有人能当你的出租车司机。仅仅是开始这些早期角色就更难了，更不用说薪水
being terrible. Yeah, absolutely. And, you know, there are definitely some of those logistic, kind of how is this going to work? And, you know, for me, I've, I moved to kind of mid Sussex, so I could get any job in Sussex and I'm fortunate enough to have been able to learn to drive. And I kind of, it was something that when I turned 17, I was like, right, let's get driving. Even though at that point I lived in London, I really didn't need to drive. I just thought, I want to do this. And, you know, if we think also about our intersectionalities, I, there are many parts of my identity that are privileged compared to other people. So being a male and a white male and living in London as well, there are there are so many different positions of privilege
糟糕透顶了。是的，绝对是。而且，肯定有一些后勤方面的问题，比如这该怎么运作？对我来说，我搬到了苏塞克斯中部，这样我就能在苏塞克斯找到任何工作，而且我很幸运能够学会开车。当我17岁时，我就想，好吧，让我们学开车。尽管那时我住在伦敦，我根本不需要开车。我只是想，我想做这件事。而且，如果我们也考虑我们的交叉性，我身份中有许多部分相比其他人是享有特权的。比如作为男性、白人男性，而且住在伦敦，我所处的特权地位
that I also hold alongside some more difficult parts of my identity, which, you know, have made parts of the journey easier. So driving is one of those. But certainly there are so many that have made it equally as difficult. So I think, you know, when I applied for my first assistant psychologist post, the way that I was able to even that out was through kind of disclosing my identity to a service that worked with care experienced children. So, you know, that for me felt like I kind of had my foot in the door, that I could kind of give them a kind of in-group knowledge that maybe they wouldn't have been able to have otherwise.
与我身份中一些更困难的部分并存，这使得旅程的某些部分变得更容易。所以开车就是其中之一。但当然，也有很多因素让它变得同样困难。所以我想，当我申请我的第一个助理心理学家职位时，我能够平衡这一点的方法是向一个与有照护经历儿童合作的服务机构披露我的身份。所以，对我来说，这感觉就像我迈出了第一步，我可以给他们一种他们可能无法以其他方式获得的群体内知识。
And I really would say that it's about thinking about parts of you that you feel comfortable to kind of capitalize on and use to even out some of the disadvantage that you might have had. And that was my way of doing it. And, you know, luckily I was fortunate enough to have learned to drive. And at that point, I had a car. Then on the Banffor salary, having to fill up my car with petrol, that was difficult. but there are so many different things that can make it hard. And, you know, I didn't have to get another job alongside. I'm quite good at budgeting sometimes,
我真的会说，关键在于思考你觉得可以利用的自身部分，并用它们来平衡你可能遭受的一些劣势。这就是我的做法。而且，幸运的是，我有幸学会了开车。那时，我有一辆车。然后在四级薪水下，还要给车加油，这很困难。但有太多不同的事情会让它变得困难。而且，我不需要同时做另一份工作。我有时很擅长预算，
unless it comes to Black Friday and there are some interesting things on sale. But yeah, and I think that for me made it easier, but I had to make sacrifice. I had to capitalize on parts of my identity. and I had to do things that maybe other people may not have had to do. And it's important to keep that in mind, particularly going forward onto training, because these things might serve as a real kind of advantage.
除非到了“黑色星期五”，有一些有趣的商品在打折。但是的，我认为这对我来说让事情变得更容易，但我不得不做出牺牲。我不得不利用我身份中的某些部分，我不得不做一些其他人可能不需要做的事情。记住这一点很重要，特别是在进入培训阶段时，因为这些事情可能会成为一种真正的优势。
You might have built this sense of kind of grit or resilience that you can use to help you get through. But you might have also got to a point where you're feeling burnt out. You're feeling quite tired. And it's okay to feel that way. And, you know, there are moments. where I have felt that way as well. And it's about finding a way that you can balance these things out,
你可能已经建立了一种毅力或韧性，可以用来帮助你度过难关。但你也可能已经到了感到精疲力竭的地步。你感到很累。感到那样是可以的。而且，有些时刻我也曾有过这种感觉。关键在于找到一种平衡这些事情的方法，
use what you've got to your advantage, and know that it's okay to do that, while also appreciating that you can do that because there are things that have been really difficult for you. And certainly that was my experience coming into it. Yeah, and I had the sense of you wanting to make sure that you were able to live independently, and able to apply to a job here and there and then not be the barrier of, oh, I can't get a bus or I can't get a train.
利用你所拥有的优势，并知道这样做是可以的，同时也要意识到你能做到这一点，是因为你经历过一些非常困难的事情。当然，这就是我进入这个领域时的经历。是的，我感觉到你想要确保自己能够独立生活，能够在这里或那里申请工作，而不是成为“哦，我坐不了公交车或火车”的障碍。
So it's like it was always important to you to be able to be, yeah, able to be in the driving seat metaphorically and really, literally, that's the word, isn't it, to be able to take you in the direction you wanted to go because maybe so much of your story has been dependent on others having the time or having the, interest or or caring enough and actually you were like I haven't I can't take that risk I can't take that gamble I need to I need to be in you know in control of my own destiny so I love that you learn to drive and that you're like this this is happening and actually just before we hit record you know I asked you how old you are I hope that was okay that I did that and you told me that when you started training you were 23 and I said well I think you're the youngest trainee I've ever known in that case, but you don't seem 24 now. You seem older than your years. And I think
所以这就像你一直很看重能够，是的，能够坐在驾驶座上，隐喻上和实际上都是如此，这就是那个词，不是吗？能够带你走向你想去的方向，因为也许你的故事中太多部分依赖于他人的时间或兴趣，或者是否足够关心。而实际上你当时的想法是：我不能冒那个险，我不能赌博，我需要，我需要掌控自己的命运。所以我很喜欢你学会了开车，而且你当时想：这事儿必须成。而且，实际上就在我们录音之前，我问了你多大，希望我那样做没问题。你告诉我你开始培训时是23岁，我说，好吧，那我认为你是我认识的最年轻的实习生，但你现在看起来不像24岁。你看起来比实际年龄成熟。我想
when you've been through adverse experiences, or even just different experiences where you've had to hold your shit together a bit more and be more self-controlled and drive your own agenda, I think that just, would you agree, it ages you, makes you grow up quick? 100%. And it's it's kind of a socialisation process, I suppose, I would see it as to some extent, that you kind of, you have to walk the walk and talk the talk. You know, you've got to make sure that you can kind of show people that you've got that. You've got that kind of sense that, you know, you can do this. And I think it was a really lovely observation to hear that, you know, how you viewed kind of my experience of coming into it. And I think it's really true.
当你经历过逆境，或者仅仅是经历过一些不同的事情，让你不得不更多地控制自己，更加自律并推动自己的议程时，我想这只是，你同意吗，它让你变老了，让你成长得很快？百分之百。这在某种程度上是一个社会化过程，我认为，你必须言行一致。你知道，你必须确保你能向人们展示你拥有这些。你拥有那种感觉，你知道，你可以做到。听到你如何看待我进入这个领域的经历，这是一个非常可爱的观察。我认为这是真的。
that, you know, I had to develop this real kind of go with the hyper independence that often we will see people develop when they've had adverse experiences. And sometimes it can be really disadvantageous, but also it can help you through so many different things. And I do think that some of me being in this position now comes from not being able to take the risk on other people and having to go with that independence and having to kind of really hold on to myself and kind of develop that secure attachment to myself and my knowledge that I can do this, which is, it's been a really hard journey. And naturally, there are times where you doubt yourself and you think, oh, I really wish someone was there to, especially, you know, when you might be
我不得不发展出这种真正的超独立性，当我们经历过逆境时，人们通常会发展出这种特质。有时它可能非常不利，但它也可以帮助你度过许多不同的事情。我确实认为我现在处于这个位置，部分原因是我无法在别人身上冒险，不得不选择那种独立，不得不真正坚持自我，并发展出对自己和知识的这种安全依恋，相信我可以做到。这是一段非常艰难的旅程。当然，有时你会怀疑自己，你会想，哦，我真希望有人在那里，特别是，你知道，当你可能
feeling, as I mentioned earlier, burnt out or sick or, you know, whatever's coming up for you. You just want someone there to just make it easier. And sometimes a lot of the time, people with care experience won't have that. And so you do have to develop that kind of ability to hold yourself. And, you know, when you go into training and you start to become a clinical psychologist, you're on that pathway. Part of that, for me, has been about leaning on my fellow trainees and leaning, on the support that the course provides and knowing that it's been hard to get here and you've had to make quite a lot of sacrifice to get here, but now is the time that you can kind of do
感到，正如我之前提到的，精疲力竭或生病，或者，无论你遇到什么。你只是希望有人在那里让事情变得更容易。而有时，很多时候，有照护经历的人不会有那种支持。所以你确实必须发展出那种掌控自己的能力。而且，当你进入培训并开始成为一名临床心理学家时，你就在那条道路上了。对我来说，这部分内容一直在于依靠我的实习生同伴，依靠课程提供的支持，并知道走到这一步很艰难，你不得不做出很多牺牲才能走到这里，但现在是时候你可以
what you haven't been able to do, which is lean on people, feel the support and kind of feel the love that other people have for you that feels really foreign sometimes, but it's usually always been there with your chosen family and friends, but maybe it's been harder to feel and you've had to kind of not take the risk and just do things alone. And now you don't have to. So that's really been my experience of getting onto training. And that's a really valuable reflection. Yeah, it's that really powerful idea of forever people, you know,
做你以前无法做到的事情了，那就是依靠别人，感受支持，并感受其他人对你的爱。这有时感觉很陌生，但它通常一直存在于你的选择家庭和朋友中，但也许很难感受到，你不得不不去冒险，只是独自做事情。现在你不必这样了。所以这就是我进入培训的经历。这是一个非常有价值的反思。是的，这是一个关于“永远的人”的非常强大的想法，你知道，
and it's whether you've ever really allowed yourself to feel like someone is a forever person. And if someone tells you they are, it's whether you really can put, both feet in there and feel that or whether you're always sort of slightly ready to look after yourself. And ultimately, as a mummy and as a wife and as a psychologist, I would hope that there does become that comfortability with that sense of family and connection and, you know, genuine friendships where you know that you can take as well as as well as give and that that's okay you don't always need to be the fixer or the helper that it's okay to say at shall really struggling at the moment could you could you come to my house instead or could we just speak
这取决于你是否真的允许自己觉得某人是“永远的人”。如果有人告诉你他们是，这取决于你是否真的能投入双脚去感受，还是你总是稍微准备好照顾自己。最终，作为一名母亲、妻子和心理学家，我希望人们能对那种家庭和联系感感到舒适，你知道，真正的友谊，在那里你知道你可以索取也可以给予，而且这没关系。你不必总是成为那个解决问题的人或帮助者，说“我目前真的很挣扎，你能来我家吗？”或者“我们能更经常地通电话吗？”或者“我们能这样做吗？你能只做我的朋友吗？”就像，我（你知道，这不一定需要公开谈论，这可能感觉太暴露了），但我最终只是希望你和任何有照护经历的人能够有那种深长的呼气。你知道我的意思吗？当你感到满足，你有你最喜欢的毯子，而且实际上你周围的人感觉就像他们是你的团队。
more regularly on the phone or can you can we do this can you just be my friend like and i you know this isn't you don't necessarily need to open up about this this might be felt too exposing but I would just ultimately want for you and for anyone that's care experienced to be able to have that deep exhale. Do you know what I mean? Where you're like you have that contentment, you've got your favourite blanket, and actually the people around you feel like they are on your team. Yeah, definitely. And I mean, so I have so many parallels with that experience of kind of now it's, I can exhale now and I can kind of relax a little bit. They say when you get on the course, you're no longer in competition with your peers.
是的，绝对是。而且我的意思是，我与那种“现在我可以呼气了，我可以稍微放松一下”的经历有很多相似之处。他们说当你进入课程时，你就不再与同龄人竞争了。
And you do really feel that and you kind of feel this community, which I've, you know, grown to feel slightly more comfortable with. But certainly as well, and, you know, I'm also thinking as well for most practitioners and most people on my course as well, there will be some form of lived experience that they've had that kind of touches a part of them when we're doing the lecture content or something. something comes up in a relationship that they've had outside or kind of in therapy with someone, it can be really difficult for so many different people. And I think this is something that applies beyond care experience, but is equally as important as. And I suppose for me, my experience
你确实能感觉到这一点，你感觉到这种社区感，我已经（你知道）逐渐感到稍微舒服一点了。但当然，而且，（你知道）我也在为大多数从业者和课程中的大多数人考虑，他们也会有一些生活经历，当我们在做讲座内容时，会触动他们的一部分。在他们之外的关系中，或者在与某人的治疗中，有些事情会浮现出来，这对许多不同的人来说可能真的很困难。我认为这适用于照护经历之外，但同样重要。我想对我来说，我的经历
has definitely been difficult. I've had some kind of important people in my life. I've had some family and friends that have always fortunately been there for me, but I've also had people that haven't been there for me. And I think when you're at such young age as, you know, using the knowledge that we know, naturally, if you kind of balance the odds, the body and the brain tells you it's too risky to trust anyone. If I've had this done to me before,
绝对是困难的。我生命中有一些重要的人。我有家人和朋友，幸运的是他们一直都在支持我，但我也遇到过没有支持我的人。我认为当你处于如此年轻的年龄时，正如（你知道）利用我们所知道的知识，自然地，如果你平衡一下几率，身体和大脑会告诉你信任任何人风险太大。如果我以前经历过这种事，
it's probably going to happen again, and I can't take that risk. So I suppose for me, it's been about kind of training my body and training my brain to go, now it's okay. And it's been okay for a while. But kind of particularly now, when you've got the support, you've got this really tangible network of people that you can come out of that fight, really, come out of that fight or flight, your threat system. And you can just be and feel.
它很可能会再次发生，我不能冒那个险。所以我想对我来说，这在于训练我的身体和大脑去想：现在没关系了。而且这种情况已经持续了一段时间。但特别是现在，当你有了支持，你有了这一群你可以从中走出来的、真正有形的人际网络，真的，从那种战斗或逃跑、你的威胁系统中走出来。你就可以只是存在并感受。
what being with and connecting with feels like. So that's been a really important part of my journey of kind of developing those longer standing relationships with people that you can give and take from. And I was, you know, last weekend, I was up in Wolverhampton with one of my friends, driving all the way there and back, which I was more than happy to do
与人相处和联系的感觉是什么样的。所以这一直是我旅程中非常重要的一部分，即发展那些你可以从中给予和索取的长期关系。而且我（你知道）上周末在伍尔弗汉普顿和我的一个朋友在一起，开车往返，我非常乐意这样做，
because she wanted to pick up a new puppy that she had found. And it's kind of these relationships that you do developed that are linked with the journey that you've been on, you know, in clinical psychology, but also applicable outside, that kind of train you without you realizing. It's kind of an implicit or a kind of unknown process that, you know, as you grow older and as you have this security and this support network, you start to feel differently. And I'm really grateful for that. I hope you got to spend some time with that puppy. Yeah, because it's a pattern. and matching part of our brain that's kind of driven by the amygdala that's looking for threat,
因为她想去接一只她找到的新小狗。正是这些你发展的、与你所经历的旅程相关联的关系，在临床心理学中，但也适用于外部，它们在你不经意间训练了你。这是一种隐性的或未知的过程，（你知道）随着你年龄的增长，随着你拥有这种安全感和支持网络，你开始有不同的感觉。我对此非常感激。我希望你有机会和那只小狗待一会儿。是的，因为这是一种模式。大脑中由杏仁核驱动的寻找威胁、
looking for danger. And it's, it kind of takes you from being that bird in the garden that's kind of peck, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, always looking for that threat and that, that kind of risk to self. To actually a really lovely example that I was watching on TikTok yesterday. Oh, can't you lose days on TikTok sometimes. Where someone has trained two robins to come into her home and feed there and be around her and land on her hand and her garden and like her garden furniture and she's done that over time by being a safe person by picking actually the type of food that she realizes the robin likes best to help the robin know actually I'm a safe person and she said something really powerful she said I've realized from all
寻找危险的部分。它把你从花园里那只啄食、看、看、看、看、看、看、看、看、看、看、看，总是寻找威胁和那种对自身风险的鸟，变成了实际上我在TikTok上看到的另一个非常可爱的例子。哦，有时在TikTok上真的会浪费时间。有人训练了两只知更鸟进入她的家，在那里喂食，待在她身边，落在她的手上，在她的花园里，还有她的花园家具上。她通过成为一个安全的人，通过选择她意识到知更鸟最喜欢的食物，来帮助知更鸟知道“实际上我是一个安全的人”，她做到了这一点。她说了非常有力的话，她说：“我从所有关于知更鸟的研究中意识到，实际上平均寿命大约是13个月。
the research I've done about robins that actually the average lifespan is about 13 months. And that means that I might not be with these robins for much longer. But actually, biologically, they can get to be 20 years. It's just that they rarely do because they have such stressful experiences where they don't have enough food. And I think for me, there's that parallel, isn't there, that if you find you're safe and forever people, life can be so much more comfortable and ultimately you will be less stressed and you will live longer, I really hope. So sorry to compare you to Robbins, but it just felt, it felt really powerfully important there. Definitely.
这意味着我可能不会和这些知更鸟在一起太久了。但实际上，从生物学上讲，它们可以活到20岁。只是它们很少能活到那个岁数，因为它们经历了太多压力，没有足够的食物。”我想对我来说，这有一个平行线，不是吗？如果你发现你是安全的和“永远的人”，生活可以舒适得多，最终你会减少压力，你会活得更长，我真的希望如此。所以很抱歉把你和知更鸟相比，但它在那里感觉非常有力且重要。绝对是。
And I felt myself and I said, wow, when you're telling the story, because, A, birds are just so skittish, aren't they? They never come up to you. They always fly away. And you don't often hear that story of kind of developing a relationship like that. And, you know, it is a good comparison to make. It's a really good analogy because I think there are times where, as you say, the amygdala sees someone or something or what could have been a positive experience as a threat. And so naturally, it's not something that we explore. But through trying time and time again and kind of training our body and our brain to notice what else, you know, are there safe parts about?
当我听到这个故事时，我感觉到我自己，我说“哇”，因为，A，鸟儿就是那么胆小，不是吗？它们从不靠近你。它们总是飞走。你很少听到那种发展出这样关系的故事。而且，（你知道）这是一个很好的比较。这是一个非常好的类比，因为我认为有时，正如你所说，杏仁核将某人或某事或本可以是积极的经历视为威胁。所以自然地，这不是我们探索的东西。但通过一次又一次地尝试，并训练我们的身体和大脑去注意还有什么，（你知道）这个经历或这个人有安全的部分吗？
this experience or this person and can we think more about those and feel those slightly you know more deeply eventually you can get used to it and i suppose for me in my experience it's it has been a long time um but definitely i i really like that comparison to a robin um and their beautiful birds so i'm going to take that as a compliment as well absolutely absolutely and before we hit record you know, you were telling me that actually your experience in the care system started incredibly young. I think you said you were in the year one. And that's, you know, that's just a lot. That's a lot for you of you to have had to bear from a young age. And I'm just, you know, as a mummy, I'm just really sad that happened to you. Yeah, and your experiences have been different.
我们能更多地思考这些并感受这些，（你知道）稍微更深一点，最终你可以习惯它。我想对我来说，在我的经历中，这已经是很长一段时间了，嗯，但我绝对，我真的很喜欢那个与知更鸟的比较，它们是美丽的鸟，所以我也会把它当作一种赞美。绝对是，绝对是。而且在我们录音之前，（你知道）你告诉我，实际上你在照护系统中的经历开始得非常早。我想你说你是在一年级。而且那是，（你知道）那真的很多。那对你来说，从很小的时候就不得不承受这么多。我只是，（你知道）作为一名母亲，我真的很遗憾那发生在你身上。是的，你的经历不同。
And I'm not suggesting that everybody that's been raised by their families have had gold standard A treatment, like a star treatment, because they haven't, have they? And I know that kind of in the care system recently, there'd been a change because actually it was always felt that it was in the child's best interest to retain a relationship with their biological parent. And I think I'm right in saying that's changed recently because even children that have been born as a result of rape have sometimes been asked to maintain a relationship with their birth father. Well, in actual fact, that's not even, you know, just a whole host of complicated things there. But I believe it's changed so that you don't have to always maintain that and that the child's voice can be listened to more. but I just think it is harder to have been through what you've been through. That's in a nutshell what I'm saying. And as a mummy of two boys, I'm just, you know,
我并不是说每个由家人抚养长大的人都得到了黄金标准的A级待遇，像明星一样的待遇，因为他们没有，不是吗？我知道（你知道）在照护系统中最近发生了一些变化，因为实际上人们一直认为保留与亲生父母的关系符合儿童的最大利益。我想如果我说最近这种情况发生了变化，我是对的，因为即使是因强奸而出生的孩子，有时也被要求与他们的生父保持关系。好吧，实际上，那甚至不是（你知道）仅仅是一大堆复杂的事情。但我相信它已经改变了，所以你不必总是维持那种关系，而且儿童的声音可以被更多地倾听。但我只是认为经历过你所经历的事情更难。这就是我所说的核心。作为两个男孩的母亲，我只是，（你知道）
I'm really moved by what you've been through, both as a child, as an adolescent and currently. Yeah. And I think you are right in saying that I think there have been some kind of policy reviews that really did look into the experiences of children currently in care. And I think you are right in saying that that's now no longer kind of a prerequisite that you must have contact with family.
我真的被你的经历所感动，无论是作为孩子、青少年还是现在。是的。而且我认为你说得对，我认为确实进行了一些政策审查，真正审视了目前在照护系统中的儿童的经历。而且我认为你说得对，现在不再（你知道）是一种必须与家人保持联系的前提条件。
And oftentimes, you know, in my experience, and I'm happy to share some of this, that, you know, as you said, I came into care when I was in year one. So it was sort of around five, six years old. And then I was in care from a foster. for about four years and then I went to get adopted from London all the way to Wakefield and that didn't work out after a few months so then I came back to the same foster carer thank goodness we know what you know the impact of continuity can have and the same
而且通常情况下，（你知道）在我的经验中，我很乐意分享其中的一些，（你知道）正如你所说，我在一年级时进入了照护系统。所以大约是五、六岁。然后我在一个寄养家庭待了大约四年，然后我从伦敦一直被送到韦克菲尔德去被收养，几个月后那没成功，所以我回到了同一个寄养照顾者那里，谢天谢地，我们知道（你知道）连续性的影响，以及同一个
therapist so you know two really important cornerstones of you know my early life that remained the same through a difficult time And I suppose for me, through that part of my experience, through going to be adopted, I had often said, has anyone stopped to ask me how I feel? Nobody's asked me what I think and whether I'm happy with this. And I suppose it speaks to this wider kind of pressure that's on systems nowadays, that, you know, there aren't enough foster carers. There are, you know, the caring profession is really on its knees.
治疗师，所以（你知道）我早年生活中两个非常重要的基石，在困难时期保持不变。我想对我来说，通过那部分经历，通过去被收养，我经常说，有人停下来问过我的感受吗？没有人问过我的想法，以及我是否对这个感到满意。我想这说明了当今系统所面临的这种更广泛的压力，（你知道）没有足够的寄养照顾者。有，（你知道）照护行业真的处于崩溃边缘。
There's no one. There's not many people. And I think it can be really difficult. And, you know, as you were saying as well, we're not saying that all families that, you know, all people that live with their, you know, chosen or biological family have better experiences. Definitely there are really difficult times. And I suppose the difference that really for me, feels quite important with care experience and, you know, individuals that have been estranged,
没有人。没有多少人。而且我认为这可能真的很困难。而且，（你知道）正如你所说，我们并不是说所有与（你知道）他们选择的或亲生家庭住在一起的人都有更好的经历。绝对有非常困难的时期。我想对于照护经历和（你知道）那些被疏远的人来说，真正感觉非常重要的区别，
is that direct or tenuous contact with these systems that can add a level of pressure and a level of difficulty. And I suppose, you know, and it's really lovely to feel that kind of motherly instinct that you've got. And, you know, it's something that I've definitely experienced a lot of. And through systems as well. And the way that systems like to make sure that they're doing their best are to kind of ask you lots of questions, to collect data, to ask questionnaires.
是与这些系统的直接或脆弱的联系，这会增加一层压力和一层困难。而且我想，（你知道）感受到你拥有的那种母性本能真的很美好。而且，（你知道）这是我绝对经历过很多的事情。而且通过系统也是如此。系统确保他们尽力而为的方式是（你知道）问你很多问题，收集数据，问卷调查。
And when I was growing up, I think there was a cyclical pattern of having what were once called and I'm not sure whether they still are, but lack reviews and PEP reviews, I think, as well. And as part of it, that process. These are meetings where you kind of review how things are going, how you're feeling,
当我成长时，我想有一个循环模式，即进行所谓的（我不确定它们现在是否还是这样，但）缺乏审查和PEP审查，我想也是。作为那个过程的一部分。这些是会议，你（你知道）审查事情进展如何，你的感受，
how your school experience is going. And part of that is filling out these really boring, really annoying questionnaires. And why? Because that's how the systems in place at that time needed to be able to see how they were doing and how cared for you were. And of course, that adds another layer of difficulty onto it. For me, I, kind of got to the point where I was like, I cannot be bothered to sit on top of homework, which I probably wasn't doing, to then have to do one of these long questionnaires. And I admittedly, at one point when I was a little bit older, I started just putting random answers that I knew, I think I learnt the system and I kind of knew that if I put something
你的学校经历如何。其中一部分是填写这些非常无聊、非常烦人的问卷。为什么？因为那是当时的系统需要能够看到他们做得如何以及你被照护得如何的方式。当然，这又增加了一层困难。对我来说，我（你知道）到了那种地步，我心想：我不能为了做这些长问卷而坐在家庭作业上（我可能根本没在做）。我承认，当我在稍微大一点的时候，我开始只是填一些随机的答案，我知道，我想我学会了这个系统，我（你知道）知道如果我填了一些
down that indicated a level of risk or something going on, that, you know, they might panic. and I kind of did that at points to just kind of show that this is not, this isn't a way of caring. This is another responsibility, another level of difficulty. So I think the difference between care experience and difficult family experiences, which are just as important, particularly for practitioners, where things can be replicated in therapeutic relationships, is the relationship that care experience people have with systems. So for me, coming into the NHS and coming into kind of my training experience, it's been really important to hold on to my previous relationships with these systems
表明存在风险或发生什么事情的内容，（你知道）他们可能会恐慌。我（你知道）在某些时候这样做只是为了表明这不是一种照护方式。这是另一种责任，另一层困难。所以我认为照护经历和困难的家庭经历（这对从业者来说同样重要，特别是当事情可以在治疗关系中被复制时）之间的区别，是照护经历的人与系统的关系。所以对我来说，进入NHS并进入（你知道）我的培训经历，保持我与这些系统的先前关系一直非常重要，
and know that there might touch parts of me that feel really uncomfortable. And, you know, is that something I'm ready to do? Yeah. And if you are in a relationship, then, with your super, where they do want to be quite maternal. Is that their personal style or is this is that what your relationship with them is eliciting? And for me I would say it probably is my personal style. So I do I do mother people. It was observed just at the weekend when I was with a load of my
并知道它们可能会触动我感觉非常不舒服的部分。而且，（你知道）这是我准备好做的事情吗？是的。如果你与你的主管有关系，他们确实想表现得非常有母性。那是他们的个人风格，还是你的关系引发了这种风格？对我来说，我会说这可能就是我的个人风格。所以我确实（你知道）像母亲一样对待人们。就在周末我和我的一群朋友在一起时，有人观察到了这一点。
qualified psychologist friends, you know, they were all going off on their train journey and I was like, oh, does anyone want any kombucha? I've got some in my bag. I was like giving out these tins of kombucha and one of my friends. I've known her since we're assistants when you're taking care of us, aren't? You're giving us gifts to make sure we're going to be okay. And I was like, yes, I am. But also it's really tasty, so go and drink it. It'll be fine.
那些有资质的心理学家朋友们，你知道，他们都要去坐火车旅行，我就说，哦，有人想要康普茶吗？我包里有一些。我当时在分发这些康普茶罐头，我的一位朋友，我从我们当助理时就认识她了，她说，你在照顾我们，对吧？你在给我们礼物，确保我们一切安好。我说，是的，我是。但它也确实很好喝，所以去喝吧。没事的。
But that is just my style, you know. When I had an assistant, when I was in the NHS, we'd come and have supervision at my house. And I'd make her hot chocolate with cream and marshmallows. Like, that is just my style. Whereas if you were having that, you might think, oh, you know, she's trying to mother me. It's like, well, no, because, you know, my previous assistant was very well mothered. and this is just my style, but also maybe there's something to reflect on there. You know, what would it be like if I wasn't mothering my assistants?
但这只是我的风格，你知道。当我在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作时，我有位助理，我们会到我家进行督导。我会给她做热巧克力，加奶油和棉花糖。这就是我的风格。而如果你经历这些，你可能会想，哦，你知道，她想当我的“妈妈”。这就像是，嗯，不，因为，你知道，我之前的助理被照顾得很好，这只是我的风格，但也可能有一些值得反思的地方。你知道，如果我不像“妈妈”那样照顾我的助理，会是什么样子？
You know, every day is a school day, right? But yeah, it's, and I think thinking about some of my trainee supervisors, some of them were really nurturing. Some of them were a bit more hands off. Some of them, you know, I learned a lot from. I think all of them I learned a lot from. Some of them I've kept in my life. some of them I haven't like yeah and another reflection like biochemically sometimes I think we just
你知道，活到老学到老，对吧？但确实，我认为回想我的一些实习督导，他们中有些人真的很会照顾人。有些人则比较放手。有些人，你知道，我从他们身上学到了很多。我想我从他们所有人身上都学到了很多。有些人我一直保持着联系，有些人则没有，就像，是的，还有另一个反思，就像从生化角度来看，有时我认为我们只是
sometimes meet someone and you get on really well don't you and you feel you feel comfortable with them and listening to what you said about when you met your adoptive family like there's that sense of well what was that like for you as a young person like do you just suddenly go from hi to like this is my new mum like and when do we ask for you? for the child. When do we give them that safe space to check in with how it's feeling, whether you think this will be viable or whether everyone's kind of trying to jolly you up and, you know, smooth it over with some like, you know, plaster to make it all work and not have these cracks turn into crevices. Does that kind of make sense, Jacob?
有时会遇到一个人，你们相处得很好，不是吗？你会觉得和他们在一起很舒服，听了你说的关于你见到养父母时的情景，就像有一种感觉，嗯，作为一个年轻人，那对你来说是什么感觉？你是突然从“嗨”变成“这是我的新妈妈”吗？我们什么时候为你，为孩子提出这个问题？我们什么时候给他们那个安全的空间来检查他们的感受，无论你认为这是否可行，还是每个人都在试图让你高兴起来，你知道，用一些像，你知道，创可贴一样的东西来掩盖它，让一切看起来都行得通，而不让这些裂缝变成深渊。这有意义吗，雅各布？
Yeah, definitely. And something I've always held in mind is that we all have, And people might think differently, but I think that we all kind of have this inner child, that we kind of are parenting day to day, that will influence our relationships. And, you know, another way of thinking about it is the internal working model from Bulby's attachment theory. And, you know, for people that might not be aware of what that is, it's kind of this sense of a model of relationships and how they should be and what we should accept and how relationships have therefore been in our past that have taught us what to accept. And I suppose
是的，绝对有。我一直记在心里的一点是，我们都有，人们的想法可能不同，但我认为我们内心都有一个内在小孩，我们每天都在抚养它，这会影响我们的人际关系。而且，你知道，另一种思考方式是鲍尔比依恋理论中的内部工作模型。而且，你知道，对于那些可能不知道那是什么的人来说，这是一种关于人际关系的模型感，关于它们应该是什么样子，我们应该接受什么，以及因此我们过去的人际关系是如何教会我们接受什么的。我想
and how to be in relationships as well. And I suppose for me, coming into kind of supervisory relationships as well, I've had a real mix. I've definitely had some really kind of nurturing and motherly supervision. And I've also had some really kind of clinical supervision that's kind of more about the work and what are we doing with this case and and how is this feeling. But I think underpinning all of this is my belief that we all have an inner child that will be influencing our relationships. And naturally, sometimes these children want to share, sometimes they don't want to share, sometimes they get along and sometimes they don't.
以及如何在人际关系中相处。我想对我来说，进入督导关系时，我也有过各种各样的经历。我确实有过非常滋养和像母亲一样的督导。我也经历过非常临床的督导，更多的是关于工作，我们在这个案例中在做什么，以及感觉如何。但我认为这一切的基础是我的信念，即我们每个人都有一个会影响我们人际关系的内在小孩。自然地，有时这些孩子想分享，有时他们不想分享，有时他们相处得来，有时则不然。
And whether or not it comes out kind of explicitly and we see the children. these things coming out, they will still be there, whether or not we've got this felt sense that this relationship feels safe. And I think it's about, you know, looking under the surface about what the context is and why. So for me, in that particular experience, it didn't feel safe to be with these adoptive parents
无论它是否以某种明确的方式表现出来，我们看到了这些孩子，这些东西表现出来，它们仍然会在那里，无论我们是否有一种这种关系感觉安全的感觉。我认为这在于，你知道，透过表面看背景是什么以及为什么。所以对我来说，在那次特定的经历中，和这些养父母在一起感觉并不安全
because you're right, it felt like I was being chivied up to kind of, you know, this is a really good thing. And, but who's it good for? Because no one asked me, it's good for the system that now there's another spot for a child to be looked after by my foster carer, which, you know, is a difficult thing anyway, but really that's what it comes down to, that, you know, there's another spot open. So for the system, yes, it's a really good thing that now I, they can put a green tick and there's a good outcome that I've, I've kind of been adopted. Yeah, this is the goal.
因为你是对的，感觉就像我被催促着去，你知道，这是一件非常好的事情。但是这对谁好呢？因为没有人问过我，这对系统有好处，因为现在我的寄养照顾者可以照顾另一个孩子了，这，你知道，无论如何都是一件困难的事情，但归根结底就是，你知道，有另一个空位了。所以对于系统来说，是的，这是一件非常好的事情，现在我，他们可以打个绿勾，这是一个很好的结果，我已经，我已经以某种方式被收养了。是的，这就是目标。
And actually things aren't always as linear as that. And thinking about it in supervision and in clinical psychology as well, these reflections around relationships and kind of what we think relationships should be are so important for how we are with clients in the room and how we approach clients and how we show them empathy and kind of just relate on a personal as well as professional level. and in supervision as well. And I think style comes into it in kind of bucket loads, whether or not someone's style feels right to you
实际上事情并不总是那么线性。在督导和临床心理学中思考这个问题，这些关于人际关系的思考，以及我们认为人际关系应该是什么样的，对于我们在房间里如何对待来访者，我们如何接近来访者，以及我们如何向他们展示同理心，以及在个人和专业层面上建立联系，都非常重要。在督导中也是如此。我认为风格在其中起到了很大的作用，无论一个人的风格是否让你感觉合适
is a completely valid point to hold. And I think when you have a difficult experience with relationships, for me, I found it really hard to know, is this style? Can I kind of question this? Can I approach this with a curious stance? Or is this my stuff coming out that's kind of, I just don't like it because it feels difficult. And a part of me is being activated.
是一个完全有效的观点。我认为当你经历过困难的人际关系时，对我来说，我发现很难知道，这是风格吗？我可以质疑这一点吗？我可以带着好奇的态度来处理这个问题吗？还是我自己的东西出来了，就像，我只是不喜欢它，因为它感觉很困难。我的一部分被激活了。
And I think growing into the profession and the more practice you have, you know, as we were talking about earlier, the more your robin becomes tamed and your amygdala sees fewer things as threats. And I suppose this is why for me, I think it's really important. to think about readiness for training and readiness for taking on that role as a trainee clinical psychologist and even taking on kind of responsible roles in caring professions, I think it's a ongoing and continual process of kind of using and disseminating these kind of points of knowledge to ourselves and also kind of integrating our own experiences. You know, I've listened to your podcast for a long time. And I know in and this is why I felt like this is a really perfect place for us to have
我认为随着职业的发展和实践的增多，你知道，正如我们之前谈到的，你的罗宾（大脑区域）变得更加驯服，你的杏仁核将更少的东西视为威胁。我想这就是为什么对我来说，我认为思考为培训做好准备，以及为承担临床心理学实习生的角色，甚至在护理行业承担责任角色做好准备，是非常重要的，我认为这是一个持续的过程，即使用和传播这些知识点给我们自己，同时也整合我们自己的经验。你知道，我听你的播客很久了。我知道，这就是为什么我觉得这是一个非常完美的地方，让我们进行
this discussion because I know that your stance is making sure that people feel compassionate towards themselves and having that's kind of holding that compassion and you know, is this the right time for me to come on to training? And it's a really difficult question for us to grapple with Before we hit record, something that we spoke about was, you know, how young I am and, you know, we mentioned it now. I could have applied to training straight from university. I could have kind of accelerated the journey even more. And I didn't. And I had a supervisor at the time that was saying, when I first applied for training, when I kind of thought,
这次讨论，因为我知道你的立场是确保人们对自己感到有同情心，并且拥有那种保持同情心，你知道，现在是我进入培训的正确时机吗？这是一个我们很难处理的问题。在录音之前，我们谈到的一件事是，你知道，我有多年轻，你知道，我们现在提到了。我本可以直接从大学申请培训。我本可以加速这个旅程。但我没有。当时我有一位督导说，当我第一次申请培训时，当我想到，
oh, I'm not sure if I'm ready, but I think I could be. So I'm going to give it a go. my supervisor was really good at that kind of keeping that open. Is this something that you're ready for? At the time, it felt really hard to think about. But now I'm really thankful I did. And it's, I'm still not sure that I'm ready for training. And I'm still, I don't know that there is this point that someone feels completely ready. But I feel that I'm coping okay. And I feel that I've got this compassion that I hold toward myself despite and including, you know, all of these difficult experiences that I can still hold a stance of compassion toward myself,
哦，我不确定我是否准备好了，但我认为我可以。所以我打算试一试。我的督导在保持开放态度方面做得非常好。这是你准备好的事情吗？当时，这感觉很难思考。但现在我很感激我这样做了。而且，我仍然不确定我是否为培训做好了准备。而且我仍然，我不知道是否有一个点让人感到完全准备好了。但我感觉我应对得还可以。我觉得我对自己保持着这种同情心，尽管包括，你知道，所有这些困难的经历，我仍然可以对自己保持一种同情的心态，
which feels ultimately the most important part. Yeah. Thank you for sharing that. And, you know, when we're looking at readiness, you know, I'm always screening people that I meet, you know, to see, you know, whether you'd tick the ready for clinical training box. And, you know, I would for you, Jacob. You seem reflective, you seem grounded, you seem able to draw on theory and to weave it inappropriately.
这感觉最终是最重要的部分。是的。谢谢你的分享。而且，你知道，当我们审视准备情况时，你知道，我总是筛选我遇到的人，你知道，看看，你知道，你是否会勾选“为临床培训做好准备”的框。而且，你知道，我会为你勾选，雅各布。你看起来善于反思，你看起来脚踏实地，你看起来能够利用理论并适当地将其融入其中。
And, you know, you seem contained, which is, you know, we don't want you to be too leaky. You know, there's got to be an element of humanness. But we've also got to think that actually we are confident in sending you out there to do clinical work with actual clients and services and family groups. And I wouldn't have any hesitation about ticking your yes box. But that's not saying that I'd expect you to be a perfect trainee. It's not saying that I'd expect myself to be a perfect supervisor. But what I would want for you and for anyone listening to this episode is to feel safe enough to be able to bring stuff to the relationship, to discuss that supervision relationship,
而且，你知道，你看起来很克制，这是，你知道，我们不希望你太“泄露”。你知道，必须有一种人性化的元素。但我们也必须考虑到，实际上我们有信心派你去与真实的来访者、服务机构和家庭团体进行临床工作。我毫不犹豫地会勾选你的“是”。但这并不是说我期望你成为一个完美的实习生。这并不是说我期望自己成为一个完美的督导。但我想要为你，也为任何收听这一集的人，感到足够安全，能够把东西带到这段关系中，去讨论那种督导关系，
to recognize that neither of you are perfect people, but to optimise that relationship really and for you ultimately to feel safe enough to be able to do that to be honest and authentic and curious and you know draw in that theory draw in reflective models and I guess ask for help when you need it really if and when you need it so that you know that you're not having to be autonomous all of the time. It's striking that balance, isn't it, between appropriate autonomy and then not being so
去认识到你们都不是完美的人，但要真正优化那种关系，让你最终感到足够安全，能够做到诚实、真实和好奇，你知道，利用那个理论，利用反思模型，我想，在你真正需要的时候寻求帮助，这样，你知道，你不必一直保持自主。这是一种平衡，不是吗，在适当的自主权和不那么
autonomous that you feel like you can operate the whole system without them, which I'm aware before we hit record for a time period you were having to do because of the way that the organisation was structured, this is before training. It's really hard, yeah, as not being so dependent
自主之间，以至于你觉得没有他们你也能操作整个系统，我意识到在录音之前有一段时间你不得不这样做，因为组织的结构方式，这是在培训之前。这真的很难，是的，作为不那么依赖
that you were having to email your supervisor, or you want to be in their office every minute or every single client you're with, you think, I wish my supervisor was seeing them. It is that fine balance. And for me, that's been something I have had to learn to be more contained. Yeah, like, I think originally when I was an assistant,
以至于你不得不给你的督导发电子邮件，或者你每分钟都想在他们的办公室里，或者你和你在一起的每一个来访者，你都想，我希望我的督导能见到他们。这是一种微妙的平衡。对我来说，这是我必须学习变得更加克制的事情。是的，就像，我想最初当我还是助理时，
I used to want to email my supervisor everything to check it or to like say, I've done this, you know, I've done this. And over time they were like, okay, but perhaps wait for supervision because that's not urgent. and it's just learning to hold that and be more contained. It's a whole process. Yeah, yeah. And it is a process.
我过去常常想把一切都发邮件给我的督导来检查，或者说，我已经做了这个，你知道，我已经做了这个。随着时间的推移，他们会说，好的，但也许等到督导时再说，因为那并不紧急。这只是学习如何保持这一点并变得更加克制。这是一个完整的过程。是的，是的。这是一个过程。
And the process continues beyond training, through training, before training. And I think it's something that, you know, picking up the language that you were using, perfect. There's no, there is no perfect. I know for me, I've always held this sense of perfectionism.
这个过程在培训之外，通过培训，在培训之前都在继续。我认为这是，你知道，拾起你使用的语言，完美。没有，根本没有完美。我知道对我来说，我一直保持着这种完美主义的感觉。
I need to, and I think training and getting onto training does cultivate that to some extent. You've got to kind of be slightly above and beyond other people to be able to get on. And it does lend itself to that kind of experience and temperament, but I suppose unlearning that and coming into these relationships in supervision where sometimes it can feel really,
我需要，我认为培训和进入培训在某种程度上确实培养了这一点。你必须在某种程度上比其他人更出色才能进入。它确实有助于那种经验和气质，但我认为摒弃这一点，进入这些督导关系中，有时会感觉非常
hard to challenge the dynamic, the power dynamic and kind of you're also then potentially challenging some of the dynamics that you've held on to in your internal working model or your kind of inner child is kind of experiencing this relationship in a certain way that feels difficult for you to challenge. But I suppose holding your self as an adult and holding yourself as a child alongside everything you've experienced positively feels really important. And that challenge of, you know, challenging the dynamics and supervision is always probably going to be there. And I think in part because you're challenging, you know, the relationship and you're kind
难以挑战这种动态，权力动态，而且你也在潜在地挑战你在内部工作模型中持有的某些动态，或者你的内在小孩以某种方式体验这种关系，这让你觉得很难挑战。但我认为，作为一个成年人保持自我，并将自己作为一个孩子与你经历过的所有积极事物放在一起，感觉非常重要。那种挑战，你知道，挑战督导中的动态可能总是会存在。我认为部分原因是你在挑战，你知道，这种关系，而且你正在
of maybe creating a tiny rupture. And repair hasn't always been easy for lots of people. So is it going to happen? Are we going to repair? But also in challenging that relationship, you might be challenging a wider system, a wider way of doing things. You might be challenging something that has always been there and hasn't been questioned because someone like you may not have been there to challenge you. So I suppose it's always a process and there is no ideal. And I think approaching these things with compassion feels really important for you to then.
可能制造了一个微小的裂痕。对于许多人来说，修复并不总是容易的。所以它会发生吗？我们会修复吗？但同时，在挑战那种关系时，你可能正在挑战一个更广泛的系统，一种更广泛的做事方式。你可能正在挑战一些一直存在且没有被质疑的东西，因为像你这样的人可能没有在那里挑战过。所以我认为这总是一个过程，没有理想状态。我认为带着同情心处理这些事情对你来说感觉非常重要，这样你才能
be able to continue to kind of always adopt that curious stance of, I wonder why these things are going on and I wonder what they can tell us. So I suppose for me that that sense of being contained really comes from practice, really comes from experience of kind of having to do these things. And, you know, as you mentioned, I did work in a system that, you know, we know isn't perfect. The NHS can be really difficult sometimes. And I did work as a lone assistant psychologist for quite some time. And, you know, practicing what I preach, I can hold on to the positives that that's really given me this newfound sense of knowing what kind of psychologist I want to be and how I can operate within these systems that can challenge our intrinsic sense of how we want to care for people,
能够继续以某种方式总是采取那种好奇的态度，我想知道为什么这些事情会发生，我想知道它们能告诉我们什么。所以我认为对我来说，那种被克制的感觉确实来自于实践，确实来自于不得不做这些事情的经验。而且，正如你提到的，我确实在一个我们知道并不完美的系统中工作。NHS有时真的很难。我确实做了很长一段时间的孤独助理心理学家。而且，你知道，实践我所宣扬的，我可以坚持那些积极的方面，这确实给了我一种新的感觉，知道我想成为什么样的心理学家，以及我如何在这些系统中运作，这些系统可以挑战我们内在的想要照顾人的感觉，
but also holding on to the negatives as well that, you know, I didn't therefore have the kind of that really motherly and that kind of really caring experience that so many people would have had. And so there will naturally be differences in the style that you learn to adopt. And it's just that. It's a style. And you can question it and you can enlighten your supervisors. you can enlighten your peers and your colleagues in a way that feels compassionate. But it is certainly a process to learn how to do that. It really is. And I wish you a career and a life full of being able to repair the ruptures
但也同时坚持那些消极的方面，你知道，我因此没有那种非常像母亲的、那种非常关怀的经历，那是很多人都会有的。所以你学会采用的风格自然会有所不同。而这仅仅是，这是一种风格。你可以质疑它，你可以启发你的督导。你可以以一种感觉有同情心的方式启发你的同龄人和同事。但这无疑是一个学习如何做到这一点的过程。确实如此。我祝愿你拥有一个充满能够修复裂痕的职业生涯和生活
that serve you best, you know? So we can't repair all ruptures, nor do we want to sometimes. But yeah, the ones that you want to keep, I hope that you're able to, to, appropriately repair them. Before we were planning this episode, we thought there might be, you know, a chance to record a couple of episodes today and to think about what other areas we might want to cover. And I've kept you talking for so long that we're not going to have a chance to do that today. But for anyone listening or watching this, if there's other future ideas
这最适合你，你知道吗？所以我们不能修复所有的裂痕，有时我们也不想。但是的，那些你想保留的，我希望你能够适当地修复它们。在我们计划这一集之前，我们认为可能，你知道，今天有机会录制几集，并思考我们可能还想涵盖哪些其他领域。但我让你说了太久，我们今天没机会那样做了。但对于任何收听或观看的人，如果还有其他未来的想法
for topics that they think would be really interesting for you and I to discuss in future, I'd love it if they'd drop that in the comments on YouTube or on Spotify. I've really, really, really valued our time talking today. And thank you for sharing your story so freely. I know I speak for myself and for our audience who wish you all the very best with your training and whatever comes next. Is there anything we haven't said, Jacob, that you kind of think we should be covering or leaving our audience with before we do finish. It's a big question, isn't it?
对于他们认为你和我未来讨论会非常有趣的话题，如果他们能在YouTube或Spotify的评论区留言，我会很高兴。我真的，真的，真的非常珍惜我们今天交谈的时间。谢谢你如此自由地分享你的故事。我知道我代表我自己和我们的听众，祝你在培训和接下来的一切中一切顺利。雅各布，我们还有什么没说的，你认为我们应该涵盖或留给我们的听众吗？这是一个很大的问题，不是吗？
And I feel, thank you so much, by the way. That's really lovely to hear. And I've really enjoyed talking on this podcast as well. It's, I think, as I said, a really apt and a lovely place to be able to talk about these things. So thank you for having me on the podcast. But I think I would echo what you say, Marianne, if people do have something that they would find important,
而且我觉得，顺便说一句，非常感谢。听到这些真是太好了。我也非常喜欢在这个播客上交谈。正如我所说，我认为这是一个非常贴切且可爱的地方，可以谈论这些事情。所以谢谢你邀请我参加播客。但我认为我会附和你所说的，玛丽安，如果人们确实有他们会觉得重要的事情，
important to talk about or to explore in more depth, I would say that that to me is more important because I can ramble on. I can talk so much, which I'm happy to do, but I don't want to do it at the expense of other people's valuable time. So if there is something that people find useful, please let Marianne know and we can definitely have a more extended conversation about these things. Absolutely. Thank you again for your time, Jacob. And yeah, I hope that you can have, we're recording this in December, but I hope you can have a really nice kind of decompression over the Christmas period. And I hope that you are spoiled and nurtured and looked after wonderfully. Thank you, Marianne. Thank you. Thank you so much to Jacob for his time. And also in sticking
谈论或深入探讨很重要，我会说那对我来说更重要，因为我可以喋喋不休。我可以谈论很多，我很乐意这样做，但我不想以牺牲别人宝贵的时间为代价。所以如果有什么人们觉得有用的东西，请告诉玛丽安，我们绝对可以就这些事情进行更深入的对话。绝对的。再次感谢你的时间，雅各布。而且是的，我希望你能有一个，我们是在十二月录制的，但我希望你能在圣诞期间有一个非常好的减压。我希望你被宠爱、被滋养，并得到美妙的照顾。谢谢你，玛丽安。谢谢。非常感谢雅各布的时间。也感谢你坚持
with me for the upload, because I know that took some time. So thank you. Thank you, Jacob. What a fascinating, thoughtful, inspiring guest. I would love it if you are able to show Jacob your support, both on YouTube and if you are listening on Spotify. It feels like a real privilege to have had Jacob's time, and I hope you feel the same way. Just after we finished, Jacob was telling me how much part of his weekly fabric this podcast has been. And I really love that idea. I won't share his background how he listens, but I would love it if you felt comfortable to share yours. Why not drop that in the comments too? You know, I'm not a beginner podcast now.
和我一起完成上传，因为我知道那花了一些时间。所以谢谢。谢谢你，雅各布。多么迷人、深思熟虑、鼓舞人心的嘉宾。如果你能支持雅各布，无论是在YouTube上还是如果你在Spotify上收听，我都会很高兴。能有雅各布的时间感觉真是一种荣幸，我希望你也有同样的感觉。就在我们结束之后，雅各布告诉我这个播客在多大程度上成为了他每周生活的一部分。我真的很喜欢这个想法。我不会分享他的背景，他是如何收听的，但如果你愿意分享你的，我会很高兴。为什么不在评论中也写下来呢？你知道，我现在不是播客新手了。
The podcast, by the time you listen to this episode, will be four years old. We've already had our 200th episode series, you know. I'm not planning on giving up any time soon, but this means that people will have started their A-levels and finished them. People will have started their degrees and finished them. People will have applied for training courses and finish them all during the life cycle of this podcast. So that is really wonderful. If you are a super fan of the show, or if you would like to support me,
这个播客，当你听到这一集时，已经四岁了。我们已经有了我们的第200集系列，你知道。我不打算很快放弃，但这意味着人们在这一播客的生命周期内，已经开始读A-level并完成了它们。人们已经开始读学位并完成了它们。人们已经申请了培训课程并完成了它们。所以这真的很棒。如果你是这个节目的超级粉丝，或者如果你想支持我，
to be able to carry on being a creator in this space for as long as possible, why not consider becoming a paid subscriber, which you can do for just a couple of pounds a month where you get exclusive behind the scenes content and footage, and you get kind of insider reflections from me. You can do that by joining my YouTube channel as a member or by joining on Apple where you can get a three-day free trial or directly through Captivate, who hosts my podcast,
为了能够尽可能长时间地在这个领域继续创作，为什么不考虑成为付费订阅者呢，你只需每月支付几英镑就可以做到，在那里你可以获得独家的幕后内容和片段，你还可以从我这里获得一些内部反思。你可以通过加入我的YouTube频道成为会员，或者通过Apple加入，在那里你可以获得三天的免费试用，或者直接通过托管我播客的Captivate，
you can get a free trial there as well. Thank you for being here. I love doing this. I love creating this content. You might be here because you're an aspiring psychologist or you might be here just because you're interested in people and human stories. Maybe for this episode you're here because you yourself have had some experience in the care system. You are care experienced.
你也可以在那里获得免费试用。谢谢你在这里。我喜欢做这件事。我喜欢创作这些内容。你可能在这里是因为你是一位有抱负的心理学家，或者你可能在这里只是因为你对人和人类故事感兴趣。也许对于这一集，你在这里是因为你自己有一些在护理系统中的经历。你是护理经历者。
Or maybe you are supporting someone who is care experienced or want to understand. and them and their position and situation better. Whoever you are, wherever you're watching or listening, you are so welcome. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者也许你正在支持某位有护理经历的人，或者想更好地理解他们以及他们的立场和处境。无论你是谁，无论你在哪里观看或收听，你都非常受欢迎。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。